did you know it around half of Europe's
500 million citizens live in rural areas
which make up over 77% of EU territory
and the farming and the agri-food
sectors together provide around 46
million jobs
Europe's rural communities and regions
are a valuable part of our heritage and
vital to our economy through the
reformed Common Agricultural Policy or
cap the EU helps farmers keep the
countryside alive and preserve the
diversity of European agriculture it
does this by the supply of regional
foods stimulating employment
entrepreneurship and by supporting rural
business with funding it invests in
research and innovation to enable
farmers to modernize and be more
efficient and it provides extra support
to help young people move into farming a
career choice that offers many
opportunities all these actions helped
make European agriculture more
competitive and sustainable farming is
not only about food it's about a
countryside and its precious natural
resources without farms and farmers
there will be little to keep rural
communities alive the new camp supports
farmers than protecting Europe's
countryside and its communities for
today tomorrow and for future
generations
Europe's Common Agricultural Policy
taking care of our roots